we're from arts project global creative
network and we're collaborating with
spec on their speck fitted case to
create the fitted arts project case it's
a collaboration of artists our network
has over 250 artists and designers from
around the world including people like
Shepard Fairey you did the Obama hope
campaign Clive Barker writer and
director of Hellraiser and a whole lot
more and we're creating original art
that's being transferred on to cases
this is curated fine art by artists
renowned artists from around the world
behind meas jim mahfood he's an artist
and comic designer and artist who does
DC Comics he's doing a pilot for Disney
right now he's one of the anchors for
spider-man for Marvel just an amazing
artist and he's basically ripping out a
design right now that's going to be
turned into a case at the end of the
show we embellish the fabric with the
graphic so this case is actually a hard
chassis that's a design from spec called
the speck fitted and the fabric actually
is nested into the hard case it's a
two-piece case that snaps apart you can
see here like the co-branded project
that we're creating together this is
from Jeremy Ville who's an artist from
Australia famous like comic and
typographer the corporation's over
leveraged the artist and get art for
free basically and make millions of
dollars off of it so in creating arts
project I teamed up with zazzlecom Inc
which is a manufacturing platform and
technology platform which allows artists
to come onto the platform and create all
kinds of products for skateboards shoes
art prints posters pretty soon speck
products in some cases artists that are
successful on our platform are making
forty forty-five percent on products
that they've created they never touch
anything has to do with manufacturing
industry
they never touch anything that has to do
with customer service we're a
made-to-order platform nothing gets made
until the credit card is swiped and
somebody purchases it for many of the
artists around the world they would
never ever get the chance to create and
grow their own indie DIY brand without
having the platform like arts projects
do it from
you